joining me now is outnumbered co-host
and former white house press secretary
under president trump kaylee mack and
mac and eddie kaylee thanks so much for
taking the time with us this has to get
exhausting kaylee this has nothing to do
with skin color and everything to do
with the ideology these lunatics
whenever you get a prominent black
conservative uh like clarence thomas
they attack them not because it's
getting with skin colors everything to
do with the ideology you're only
officially black to them if you're a
black liberal
right justice clarence thomas does not
officially represent the black community
what does that even mean sonny hostin as
if because of the color of his skin he's
supposed to think a certain way and
advocate for certain policies he can't
possibly be a strict constructionist or
an originalist or a constitution loving
justice he must be a liberal justice no
that is so wrong dan it's the same thing
they did to senator tim scott who gave
in my view the best rebuttal we've ever
seen uh to a national address which is
what president biden gave before joint
session of congress uh those responses
usually are not very good but in the
case of senator tim scott it was
extraordinary so what happened they the
left-trended uncle tim on twitter a
reference to uncle tom look at winsome
sears an amazing immigrant to this
country the first black lieutenant
governor they just ignore her they just
decide if you think this way
you're done we won't tolerate you it is
absolutely reprehensible
yeah i mean it's frustrating and i saw
our friend leo terrell on the network uh
this week and you know he was commenting
how is it this isn't even soft bigotry
kaylee it's hard bigotry treating black
voters as if they're all sup it's
mandatory that they think the same isn't
that like making they're trying to make
infants out of them i mean these are
american citizens that does it surprise
some liberals that they all think
differently i mean is this a shocker to
them
it is a shocker but look i can tell you
this it's backfiring here in the state
of florida look at governor desantis he
outperformed gop expectations with black
women by 11 percent these were school
choice moms who said no i'm not going to
think the way you want me to think when
you look at public polling president joe
biden's lost double-digit support in the
black community so you can tell people
that they have to think in this box but
i can tell you what they're walking
outside that box and they're walking
straight over to the republican party
yeah yeah no you see the numbers that's
absolutely correct i just want to move
on different topic here kamala harris
our vice president here she's supposed
to be helping this selection committee
for the supreme court seat you know she
really knocked it out of the bark as the
borders are you know listen you worked
in the white house you were in the room
i mean literally in the room for these
conversations is this a political effort
to save a reputation here because she's
really kind of failed at everything else
and hope they can kind of change the
narrative
oh for sure exactly dan you know vice
president mike pence was involved in a
myriad of matters because he did a great
job like on covet 19 for instance he led
the task force and he proved himself to
be skillful and adept but kamala harris
she couldn't get voting rights done the
borders up in flames she's failed at
every task she's been given so they said
let's give her the one done deal that we
have or in their mind they think it's a
dumb deal done deal a 50 50 senate we'll
get this liberal supreme court justice
through but wow if anyone knows how to
light a surefire fire deal on fire it is
kamala harris so you chose the one
person who may tank what in your view is
something that simply cannot be tanked
right yeah they're definitely throwing
her a life preserver trying to save her
kaylee thanks a lot for your time we
always appreciate it thank you
thanks dan hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else